i have a number of things i want to go
over with you today and the first one is
a really strange reason
to oppose helping homeless people that
this is just bizarre
uh in the state of tennessee
they've been debating a bill dealing
with homelessness
and in the midst of the debate
republican state senator frank nicely
stood up he's from strawberry plains
tennessee
and he said hey you know what
being homeless isn't the end of the
world
hitler
hitler
was able to
do things and make something of himself
even after being homeless for a little
while now he's not saying killing jews
is good but why do you go to hitler as
an example of someone who
entered the history books after being
homeless it's bizarre speaker i haven't
given you all the history lesson in a
while and i want to give you a little
history on homelessness please 19 and 10
hitler decided to live on the streets
for a while
so for two years hitler lived on the
streets and practiced his oratory and
his body language and how to connect
with pieces and then went on to lead our
life that got him in the history book so
a lot of these people it's not a dead
end they can come out of this these
homeless camps and have a productive
life
or in hitler's case a very unproductive
life
um
guys i i get he's not saying you know it
was delightful hitler was homeless and
then he came out and he was able to kill
six million jews i get that he's not
saying that
but why do you have to point to hitler
and also if hitler chose to be homeless
in order to practice his oratory skills
and uh and body language most homeless
people are not trying to build public
speaking uh skills by by being homeless
mention you know the singer jewel at one
point was really living in her car she
really was horrible backstory to it or
actor jim carrey once lived in his car
on his sister's front lawn although it's
not even really being homeless in the
sense that a lot of people are homeless
or
why why hitler
and it's this very strange
it's it's not an obsession but it's like
why why are they thinking of hitler so
much to make positive points
and here the point is listen it's not
that bad to be in these homeless camps
uh people can end up
in the history books even after being
homeless
look at hitler these people are very
strange and i think that there's
something extraordinarily wrong with
them i want to talk about the latest
grift scam from the republican party
there's a very good article in truth out
about this trump and republicans are
raking in millions of dollars with these
fascist fundraising emails now many of
you have written to me about these
emails many in our audience they don't
even know how they ended up on the
republican email list and on trump's
email list truthout's report is is it's
mind-blowing trump remains the highest
totaling fundraiser in the republican
party
experts say the fundraising emails
fueling his political ambitions
increasingly echo conspiracy theories
and employ fascist rhetoric that's true
i've seen them trump's fundraising
emails helped generate 378 million
dollars in 2020 and there's 110 million
in trump's war chest as of a couple
months ago that's more than what's been
reported by the rnc and dnc combined
the fundraising success suggests trump's
messaging resonates with many
republicans
trump's deceptive fundraising emails are
not just obnoxious if you're a supporter
subscribe to trump's email list you're
told sinister forces are destroying a
nation that rightfully belongs to
patriots like you
only trump can save america from
humiliation this is classic 20th century
rhetoric we don't have to say hitler
because it's it's it's really more like
mussolini
um it's really more more like others
some appeals appear to operate like a
sweepstakes letting you meet trump in
person or go to a top secret rally
now
we've already talked before about how at
many of these things trump's not there
there was one promoted as like have
lunch with trump but only lindsey graham
was going to be there they also used
language like trump's inner friend
circle where a select few will be
exposed to confidential information he
won't trust other people with
and uh that is similar to the q anon
stuff
it's similar to these you know fights
against elite cabals and so on and so
forth
this is classic this is a clinic in
reactionary
fear-mongering we live in a society
where so many people
just freely will turn money over to rich
people that openly despise them and that
is what we are seeing here this is the
giving culture
where these reactionaries
who trump has spent listen guys we've
said it before trump is a rich guy from
new york has spent his life trying to be
kept away from the people that make up
the bulk of his base
the people giving the small dollar
donations because that's all that they
can afford at the end of the day
and it is
what his campaign has been built on
trump doesn't like these people but he
will grip them out of every last dollar
the emails are also really a study into
cults
and i know i've said this before
but i've recently been reading about the
charles manson cult
and when you read the interviews that
the cult members would give to law
enforcement when it all kind of fell
apart
the language and the demeanor and the
tone is so similar to that which we hear
from trump supporters today
and you know as i've said before i don't
want anyone getting scammed i i don't
want i don't want anyone getting scammed
and at the same time at what point do
you say these people are determined to
be scammed they're determined to give
trump the money they're falling for the
fascistic rhetoric they're doing all of
it i don't know i don't know at what
point we say we just kind of can't
protect these people anymore i don't
know when we get there but it seems like
we're probably pretty close
uh very quickly i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this but some people
wrote to me again and they said uh what
is going on with the n-word being used
by
failed former president donald trump
this is starting to get really strange i
almost think trump's trying to just
appear to be provocative
trump multiple times now has referred to
nuclear or nuclear depending on your
pronunciation preference as the n-word
and now he did it again at some kind of
event i don't know if this is a
fundraiser or a party or what it is
trump now saying hey everybody went
crazy when i referred to nuclear as the
n-word
take a look we have the greatest nuclear
force in the world you don't want to do
that you know the i call it the n word
okay i said that to a group of people
they said there would all he said a
horrible thing i said no the nuclear
words
is that always that horrible thing the n
word
i said no the n word is the nuclear word
the nuclear word is something that's not
supposed to be discussed
you don't talk about it
you don't talk about it
why are people even clapping like it is
completely incoherent what he's saying
and people are clapping because trump
says you're not supposed to talk about
the nuclear what
about it
a serious nuclear power he's talking
about
okay so
trump now is referencing when he went on
fox news program uh i don't even know
what it's called what's the it's a
program with stuart varney it's called
uh i i don't even know what the show is
called stuart varney's program on fox
business and he played the same kind of
koi game well in hope to god you never
have to use it because it would be that
would be the tragedy of all tragedies
but if we didn't have it we couldn't
talk but i listened to him constantly
using the n-word that's the n-word and
he's constantly using it the nuclear
word
and we never
talk it we say oh he's a nuclear power
what do you guys think this is about is
this some kind of a dog whistle where
white supreme i'm making this up by the
way guys is this a dog whistle where
trump is signaling to white supremacists
i can't go around using the real n-word
but i'm going to say the n-word and
pretend i'm talking about nuclear but
i'm actually talking about the n-word
is that is it a dog whistle that only
some people understand is it trump
trying to just be provocative
by using the term n-word even if it has
nothing to do with the actual n-word
i don't know what he's trying to do it's
very very strange one last bonus clip
just about how weird things are that are
going on lately here's trump talking
about when he met matt gates's wife
uh this was over the weekend i guess at
mar-a-lago it's just all very bizarre
and i do remember when they met he came
up i said who the hell is that
not that i noticed those things but i
said who's that i said matt i don't know
how well you get along but assuming you
get along that's the one for you and now
it's uh you've come a long way together
haven't you it's a great couple and we
appreciate it and we love you both
and we're with you all the way
real weekend at bernie's vibe starting
to go there at at mar-a-lago but very
strange what's this n-word stuff about
guys let me know i really don't
understand it you can find me on twitter
at d pacman this is one of the last
times i'm going to mention this because
we're doing the event in a few days
tuesday
april 19
6 p.m we're doing a town hall event town
hall events are where you get to ask me
questions you get to berate me for
whatever you want to berate me for
it it's wide open this will be streaming
live so if you want to listen to the
town hall it'll be live at 6 p.m on the
pacman live youtube channel that's
youtube.com pacmanlive it won't be on
the regular youtube channel it won't be
on facebook it won't be on twitch it
will only be at youtube.compacmanlive
tuesday april 19th 6 pm
if you want to call in
then it's going to be via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord if you're not a member
everybody's welcome to call in however
if you do become a member we are going
to have a priority path for you to get
on the air for our paid members
everybody will get an opportunity but
it'll be easier if you're a member and
you can sign up at
joinpackman.com so that's tuesday but
still a full show of stuff coming up for
you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show of course depends
on your support through the membership
program we do an extra show every day
for our members you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
we also have the upcoming david pakman
show town hall on tuesday april 19th and
members will get priority access during
the
uh town hall which is an amazing thing
but let's not wait let's hear from
people right now we take calls via
discord on fridays at davidpakman.com
discord
and we are going to start today
with john from philly john from philly
you're on the air
john from philly please unmute yourself
you're on the air and you could talk to
me if you unmuted
and last chance
for john from philly
hmm
well that's really too bad
that's not a uh
particularly auspicious start let's put
it that way
uh why don't we go instead to evan from
is it pronounced harrogate
it's a harrogate david harrogate welcome
sir
thank you very much um i had a question
just about um kind of argentine public
opinion on the fault and that's okay
sure it's kind of a three-part question
um because i'm kind of i don't really
know how to get the republicans or
government opinion on the issue so i was
just kind of wondering do you know what
the
kind of public opinion or what the
government think is um what is your
opinion and
uh it might not be analogous but do you
think there's any kind of
taiwan type analogy to it at this point
or not i don't think that with the
falklands there's much of a taiwan
analogy at least that i would be uh able
to articulate but uh this is this is a
good question it's the uh it's the
40-year anniversary of the falklands war
the falklands are these islands off the
coast of argentina and i am from
argentina and i know that people may
expect me to have some particular hot
take or maybe even a biased view because
i'm from argentina i mean listen the uh
my understanding of public opinion in
argentina is that most argentinians
believe that the falklands should be
argentinian
um my view is that that's not at all
clear to me
um if i if you look at the the history i
don't know the full history of the
falklands but you can definitely find
periods
in the hundreds of years ago where
different populations were there to say
who controlled it i i just am not enough
of a student of it to say
uh but to me
yeah go ahead so i think i think it was
french originally and then it was kind
of uh abandoned for a while and then it
kind of flicked between spanish and
majority british reversal yeah and so
listen for me the you know sometimes
you'll see argentinian soccer matches
and people unveil flags that say the
falkland islands are argentinian and
stuff like that
for me it's an unusual hill to to look
to die on i recently saw because of the
anniversary on argentinian news they
brought like three veterans
from that three argentinian veterans and
the framing of the entire segment was
like obviously the islands are
argentinian when it's like not at all
clear from history that that's the case
and i know that people on both sides
will make very strong arguments i think
it's politically ambiguous at best
i think because one of my friends works
in the oil industry out there i think if
you have the full and stamp on your
passport you're not allowed to go to
argentina that may be
that similar that's similar to if that's
the case that's similar to there are
there are middle eastern countries where
if you've been to israel you're not
allowed to go in that that reminds me of
that there's one other historical note i
would mention
at the time
in uh at the time 40 years ago when this
war took place
uh it was very stupid to think that
argentina was going to be able to beat
the uk in a war like obviously that
wasn't going to happen and there was a
very cynical nature with which there was
propaganda value to
appearing or attempting to fight this
war because of what was going on in
argentina at the time starting to get
out of this uh you know military
dictatorship government and this type of
thing and so
a lot of people would look at it and say
it seemed really stupid to think that
argentina's military could fight the
uk's and it was
and the reason was it had propaganda
value to some degree
all right okay
cool oh yeah thank you very much all
right thank you so much for the call
yeah good i was i figured at some point
someone would ask about that because of
the uh because of the timing and someone
did let's go to our friend bitdefender
from cancun mexico this is not eric from
cancun this is a different cancun caller
who goes by bitdefender bit
you're on
hello david hello
i hope you're well um
i wanted to talk about something that
happened in mexico that i think uh some
americans ought to know uh just in case
something similar happens in the states
okay so
the 10th of april we had a
special election of sorts uh alexander
mandato which is
essentially an election where you go to
vote to
get rid of the president is it almost
like it's almost like a no-confidence
vote of the of the people right
exactly yeah now it sounds
sort of democratic but the reality of it
is that it's something that mostly
exists in um autocratic countries
and countries that
well leaders that want to campaign
constantly you know what i mean yes
especially in countries that pretend or
have democratic
systems that you know have electoral law
of sorts
but you you very well know that the
elections are not fair and free sure you
know
[Music]
venezuela ecuador
some other latin american countries have
this form i know mexico has it
given the rise of
these forms of
you know governments and uh governors
do you think uh
we will see something similar in the
states i don't think so i think it would
be
how presidential elections run
at least in theory
is so set in stone
that i don't believe that there's going
to be the putting in the in statement of
such a mechanism and also
you know as you point out one of the
ideas of it the propaganda value of it
is that you can kind of constantly be
running an election and that can
sometimes help to coalesce and organize
people
the republican party has already figured
out how to do the same thing by by
saying democrats are going to try to
steal it which is what they did in 2020.
and so they already kind of have a
mechanism to make that rallying cry so
no i don't expect that to be uh
instated in the united states
also that now that you mention it
when you know given the nature of
electoral law in your in the states um
what gives you so much confidence that
you know electoral law is so set in
stone
you know me coming from a country where
we have a an actual
federal institute dedicated to electoral
management and the states
don't really have one you know
uh i mean i don't maybe i'm naive to
think that but the the only real sense i
have is that if anything was going to
structurally change the way elections
are done it would be something like the
national popular vote interstate compact
where states can decide
we'll we'll just give our electors to
the winner of the popular vote but
beyond that there's not really any
serious initiatives there i mean they're
they're trying to steal it by not
officially changing the big picture but
by doing voter suppression at the state
level uh strategic voter id closing
polling places that they're looking to
do it piecemeal rather than any with any
big mechanism like an a public no
confidence vote or that type of it's
just what they're doing so i'm basing it
on what i see
absolutely well that's about it thank
you dude all right thank you there's a
bit defender from cancun let's go next
to phil from california phil you're on
the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
hi david i had a question about uh
propaganda in general
okay and it seems like with with
propaganda it seems to have origin where
there's a voluntary actor who kind of
promulgates the initial idea of
propaganda and disperses it
but at what point does the propagate
propaganda become like a feedback loop
and people that are propagating it also
are consuming it and falling for it oh
it happens very quickly oh sorry go
ahead yeah
i was going to just say for example it
seems like putin may have fallen for his
own propaganda with his initial attack
on the ukraine and how poorly his uh
army performed
was probably partially to believe in his
own
uh
propaganda about liberating ukraine and
that he would be welcomed with open arms
i'm not sure about that i i don't i
don't think putin was that naive but i
think your principle is very much there
i i see it much more
like in the current republican party
where
i see it the other way where it's sort
of the people that fell for the
trump is really the winner propaganda
end up spreading it
and then they end up believing it
because people they've convinced start
repeating it themselves so that's the
feedback loop that i've seen
i don't know that the putin example i
don't know if i don't know how sure i am
of the putin example but your idea is
absolutely spot on
thank you david my pleasure thank you
very much for the call
a nice concise call there let's go next
to
stephanie in texas stephanie you're on
the air
stephanie in texas you're on the air
please unmute and you'll be able to talk
to me hi hello hello can you hear me hi
yes i can
hi thanks for taking my call
pleasure um and i owe you an apology
actually i tried calling a couple months
ago and i got so excited that instead of
muting my call i hung up on you so i
apologize for that oh no
so anyway and i also wanted to um uh
just let you know that we're not all
crazy here in texas but just how crazy
how crazy are things in texas right now
um and i wanted to ask you thank you for
the um you did a
piece on
uh the murder charges being dropped
against a woman who tried to seek an
abortion yes um and i you know there's a
lot of things i could
there's a lot of things i'm trying to
like you know to ask you about because
there's a lot of things going on here
right now but that's one of the ones i
think that's really first and foremost
and do you think that that's something
that um my i'm hoping my hope is it'll
lose steam over time as people
maybe get faced with these more if more
charges come up and people start
realizing it's more of a you know a wild
goose chase to some extent do you think
it's going to do in your opinion do you
think it's going to start being
less of an issue or do you think it's
become people are going to try and push
it more i think people unfortunately
stephanie i think the whole charges for
abortions thing i think it's going to be
a new tool that we're going to see a lot
of and in particular in late june the
supreme court
is going to issue a decision on a state
abortion case and their decision could
effectively overturn roe v wade if that
happens there are 22 states that
essentially ban abortion those laws will
then become the law of the land and i
think you're going to see tons of people
charged criminally
for seeking abortions and it's going to
be a dystopian nightmare
yeah and it's unfortunate because you
know obviously the roe v wade is a huge
tool that people have been able to take
advantage of and it's just not you know
i'm hoping i'm hoping that that won't be
the case but yeah unfortunately like you
said in june we kind of have a deadline
here now um have you interviewed beto
o'rourke yet or um is that something
that i've if you have have i missed it
and if you haven't do you plan on doing
that he's not been on we're interested
in having him on so far he's not shown
any interest in being on so if people
want to tweet to beto and say hey okay
go to the david pakman show we would
love to have him
yeah i think i follow him and i'm also
volunteered to um phone bank and uh and
uh not knock on doors for him so
hopefully i'll get some word out there
but yeah he's just i'm hoping that he'll
he'll have some some
pull if he gets elected hopefully it's
just it's just been so kind of crazy and
i get so frustrated people say we don't
like it then move you know that's a
really um you know generic thing to say
to people because we can't just move
it's just like our home and our business
is here and people have families and
everything yeah it's it's crazy for sure
stephanie
can you get a good bagel in texas or is
that impossible
um actually
uh
uh you know
i guess it depends i if i want to go
drive through for big i'll go to the
einstein brothers which i'm sure is like
you know pretty pretty basic but um i
have my own bagels in the air fryer
actually it's pretty funny like i make
them with um i have a air fryer and i
found a really good recipe for um it's
not like your traditional bagel so it's
not it's a little bit more like a it's a
little moisture it's like i use greek
yogurt and flour so it's just like three
ingredients basically and i do my
airfryer and it sounds more like that it
sounds more like a cake than a bagel it
kind of is but it's like it's really
good because it's like you know it's
higher in protein it's a little bit
better for you than like all the carbs
in the regular bagels sure sure
we're just all right stephanie well kind
of crazy it sounds complicated down
there but i appreciate you calling it
yeah well just kind of keep us in your
thoughts and follow us because we've got
a lot of interesting things going on
here
absolutely bagels aside a lot going on
in texas there's stephanie from texas
100 thank you very much uh all right
we're gonna take a quick break but i'm
still taking more of your calls just
hang on we will be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's go back
to discord davidpakman.com
discord we're hearing from people in the
audience the most important people let's
go to kier from scotland kier you're on
the air
hi david um i just just wondered if you
had any thoughts i don't know if you're
aware of what's happened in the uk today
but um our prime minister for the last
months
started out denying that he'd had any
parties in number 10 down the street
then he said he didn't know that it was
a party
um and then and then he said oh yes it
was a party but i wasn't aware and now
today he's been handed out um him his
wife and the chancellor of exchequer
have all been handed out 50 pound fines
yeah for breaching walk down those rules
that they wrote
um and they are all um and there's over
50 now people who live in downing street
and that have all been handed out these
fines
um
and it there's it's he's got over a 75
uh dislike with the public today in
polls today um i was just wondering if
you had any comment on it or if if you
thought because he's refusing to resign
as is his chancellor just
listen
on the resignation i can't comment on
the resignation piece you know it's
really for those it's i want to leave
that to voters and others in the uk to
comment on but if there's anything good
about this now we can look at it and say
a 50-pound fine is pathetically low and
you're you know sure that's true but i
think it's good that at least they're
being held to the standards where in
some places it would just be excused if
that's the punishment that should be
assigned i'm glad that it's being
assigned if the rules were broken also
like how much of this has to do with the
what is the definition of a party in the
uk
this is the thing is that he wrote the
rules right the people
wrote the rules about what her party was
but he doesn't seem to know himself what
a party is
which is absolutely insane to me um i'm
just well i've got you here as well um
do you think this is going to push uh
perhaps towards scotland getting another
one another independence
this specifically boris johnson's party
you mean
just the litany of things that he's done
over the last few years of just lying in
parliament and illegally pro parliament
he lied to the queen he's just i could
let the list of things i could say he's
just i'm just wondering like this is
this going to be
is this going to be the final thing
where the people of scotland are just
going to say enough is enough we're done
with you i don't know what will be the
proverbial uh straw that breaks the
camel's back but my sense for several
years in reading about scotland has been
that there's at least some clamoring for
another independence vote i mean you you
tell me is that the sense you get
i think so yes i think there's a lot of
people who previously
um either didn't vote or wanted to stay
in the union because of again lies
holding the thing yeah pulling the
referendum on the run up to the
referendum who have now just just had
enough they don't they want the fed up
with the constant lies and
just just the constant nonsense coming
out of westminster i just want done
i do wonder i'm so i'm totally sensitive
to that and you know it's
it's the people of scotland that need to
decide i'm not taking a position one way
or the other i'm wondering if you
like are you aware and does it concern
you that there may be economic
difficulties in scottish independence is
that a discussion
no that's that's not really it's not
really a problem there's a lot of sort
of people who are like oh you you take
more from england you don't it's more
it's more complex than that because we
have a lot of offshore oil and there's a
lot of other ways like we can make a lot
of money out of tourism uh the real
problem is is um
we can't have a referendum
a legally binding referendum unless
westminster says we're allowed to right
boris johnson has outright stated he
will not allow that to happen sure so
even even if the
msps decide that they're going to have a
referendum he can just ignore it and say
no you're not getting independence i
don't care what the referendum you had
says right right right right that is a
difficult situation
yeah yeah very difficult it doesn't
really feel like self-determination in
that sense
um yeah it's uh it's a bit of a sticky
situation i don't know how you get out
of it yeah
well
i really appreciate your call and uh for
you filling us in on what's going on
there
oh thank you for your time sir all right
there is keir from scotland a beautiful
phone call for sure
uh let's go next to raul in los angeles
raul go ahead
hey i'm just curious i've got two
questions i guess kind of a
vague complicated one and a bit more of
an easy specific one i'll let you choose
which do you want well i'll take the
easy one any day
how do you think the left will maintain
power during the midterm
it's not clear that they will
yeah i mean it's it's not looking good
that that's kind of how i feel i feel
like it's going to kind of be this
constant cycle of
every two years the general power
structure switches between either the
president who was just elected or who
won during the midterm and
it's just kind of a chaotic system and i
as a young person feel kind of
lost within it i'm more of a leftist but
neither party really speaks to me you
know last candidate was
was bernie and now i'm just kind of lost
so what what do you plan to do in
november do you even plan to what's your
set what's your plan
um i'll i'll vote
democrat that's kind of just what i've
always done i kind of
tend to just vote for who
tends to my politics
but i also kind of just prefer to focus
on local stuff because that's where my
vote actually matters
a lot of young people think that just
because of the electoral college or vote
doesn't matter when
local stuff you actually have an impact
on sure
well i think it's wise for you to to pay
attention i think it makes sense to vote
in the midterms nationally but to focus
locally makes a lot of sense to me if
more people did it the left would be
stronger
yeah yeah it's it's definitely a flaw of
the left as i see a lot of people having
um
strong ideals but not exactly context
within politics to vote certainly
certainly are you in northern or no
sorry you said l.a what part of la are
you in
uh san fernando valley oh okay okay so
that's north of the city right yeah yeah
it's it's la county as well
you know it's the largest metropolitan
in north america something like that so
that's what they tell me all right well
i appreciate the call
yeah thank you all right there's raul
from l.a
disheartened but staying engaged which i
think is a great thing
let's go to william from las vegas
william you're on the air
hello david can you hear me i can hear
you fine i i i just got back from vegas
a few days ago
i know i was actually down at the strip
i was kind of keeping an eye to see if i
spotted you but chances are i was pretty
far from you
um so sir
i was wondering if you could help me
craft
uh
a water cooler argument
which i'm sure a lot of other people are
having okay um and
it may sound off the rails but we'll end
it together
so from my understanding in the early
2000s school districts started to teach
common core math
and it took a while for
for teachers to get trained on how to
teach common core math with a lot of
resources curriculum testing and then
it's still
working out so we're actually using that
as the standard
so knowing that or understanding that
with the argument
that critical race theory is being
taught right now
wouldn't it make sense that it took
time to teach
teachers
a graduate level from what i understand
a social or humanities elective
uh and
i'm sorry i lost my train of thought
um
[Music]
would it make sense that it took time to
instruct teachers how to teach this very
complicated
theory
from k to 12 even though it's not
necessarily in the curriculum uh and
every time i have this argument my
question is well which curriculum is
teaching this which public school uh
because they all publish their
curriculum i've not gotten an answer on
that but but that's kind of where where
i'm formulating my argument as we go
towards the midterms
i but so what do what is the argument
you're trying to make you're trying to
make the argument that critical race
theory just isn't being taught i mean
it's basically not being taught that's
that's true as far as k-12 is concerned
but what what is the argument you're
trying to formulate
uh so you're right so it's basically an
association with uh when people say
they're teaching critical race theory i
say well well how is this happening when
they they trained teachers for years how
to teach common core math and we've not
heard anything about teachers being
taught critical race theories so
basically it's a debate
okay let me see if i understand so
you're saying
we knew for so long
that this thing called common core math
was coming in and we know teachers were
being trained on how to teach it because
the teachers can't teach it unless
they're trained
if critical race theory is really
everywhere
how is it everywhere given that the
teachers haven't even been trained how
to teach it
we landed it safely that's exactly the
point i was trying to make yes yeah
that's that's interesting i think the
the problem is here's how the right will
respond they'll say no no no here's the
thing
college
that the colleges that the teachers went
to
their entire framework is critical race
theory so the teachers already have the
knowledge
they'll say something like that so i
don't know that you would convince too
many people unfortunately
and my maneuver to that is well teachers
don't teach anything that's not on the
curriculum
they'll say but they are that they'll
just say no but they are teaching it
they're teaching it oh so so it's the no
true scotsman that they'll come back
with yeah probably
okay yeah all right
it's an uphill battle my friend but i'm
glad you're thinking about it
well i'm definitely thinking local and
hopefully you uh you enjoyed las vegas
while you were here i did all right
good all right thank you sir okay very
good take care there is a beautiful
phone call from las vegas hard to hard
to beat that
why don't we go next to um
let's go to casey from oklahoma city
casey you're on the air
hey everybody hear me okay yes i can
um with the texas heartbeat
act
oklahoma planned parenthood i mean they
saw a jump i think in
roughly like two thousand twenty five
hundred percent in uh patients
uh but governor stanton who's often the
little brother of the states and
governors like you know desantis and
abbott uh just signed a law that would
basically upend it here in oklahoma and
ban it yep to include like hundred
thousand dollars in fines plus ten-year
prison sentence we did cover that story
earlier this week it's crazy what
oklahoma's doing on abortion yeah yeah
um
but i find that we often talk about at
least in the counter we talk about rape
and incest but one of the things i never
hear about is teen pregnancy and if we
look at the top states of teen
pregnancies greater than
30 per every thousand burst guess what
they're they're all republic republican
states of course south carolina arizona
alabama tennessee you know i can go down
the list
do you think it would
help these pro-life people to think
twice when
we we frame it that the the teen
pregnancies who are their daughters
uh do you want them to keep that child
or or do they say well morally my
daughter should keep it
um so
usually they will sidestep this issue
you're absolutely right which is the
places that uh have the highest rates of
teen pregnancy are mostly red states
that's absolutely true
republicans will sidestep this by saying
if we were correctly teaching
abstinence-only same
abstinence-only sex education they
wouldn't be getting pregnant in the
first place now of course they're wrong
but they want the total package which is
ban abortion
and teach abstinence only you know it
doesn't work i know it doesn't work but
that's what they will say
i mean i would think the counter to that
is isn't that what you already preach in
your states and obviously it's not
working it's not working no but then
they'll come in and they'll say no but
these public schools with the critical
race theory and the gender stuff and the
teaching kids how to have sex and these
things they'll just say it's not it's
what we want but it's not actually
happening teachers are injecting it into
the classroom
yeah and it's uh i left a voicemail last
night about uh radio station here
locally and and if you go to like the
fcc
uh they can't do anything as far as
freedom of speech which i'm all for you
know freedom
uh but the the propaganda from because
they're playing like infowars
and and talking about demonic baby
pedophile all this stuff is just
infuriating and i don't know
the solution to it because it's just
making people stronger in their beliefs
that are just untrue it's lunacy it's
lunacy yeah
well listen good luck there in oklahoma
because it's getting pretty grim i'm not
going to lie yeah it is
yeah all right casey thank you for the
call thank you all right there's casey
from oklahoma the site of a horrifying
horrifying horrifying
abortion bill let's go to tristan from
boston tristan you're on the air
david can you hear me yes i can
cool
it occurred to me recently uh have you
considered writing a book
yes uh in fact i'm working on a proposal
right now it's a big project it's a long
process but i am working on that right
now
wow that's actually pretty cool yeah uh
if you don't mind me asking uh
what is the subject i i don't want to
say because we're still workshopping it
and then it i might end up kind of
self-cutting you know i don't want to do
that
does it
include elements of many subjects it
actually does it actually does yeah it's
a it's a multi-disciplinary proposal
i mean
that would feel like the
the main topics the ideas for the main
topics would be pretty obvious
well we'll find out won't we tristan
considering you're considering your
fields of expertise sure
sure yeah no when i have more to say
about it i absolutely will but it's
something i am working on
that's actually great to hear i would
i would 100
i'm totally pumped to hear that
well good it sounds like at least i'd
sell one copy
yeah can't wait to see it all right
tristan thank you so much
awesome all right there's tristan from
boston asking about
a book project
thanks to everybody who called in my
apologies to everybody i couldn't get to
we'll take calls again and for now we
will take a very quick break and be
right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's review this week's
mailbag if you have a message for me you
can email it to info davidpakman.com
many many messages come in every week
i think
probably
a thousand or so
and we can only look at you know 10 or
so so just understand that please be
polite please be respectful info
davidpakman.com all right first email
this week came in from christopher who
also signed his email keith
i don't know
a christopher says
after this weekend's trump rally
you talk crap about trump
how much is your gas now compared to
when trump was in office well i drive an
electric car so my gas hasn't changed
but i understand the point how about
your grocery bill yes it's higher
but what does joe biden have to do with
that
how about everything you buy bring way
up with the democratic leadership
don't understand why you dummies can't
look at numbers instead of your personal
political opinion f biden and fu well
that's exactly what i do
regardless of my political opinion which
is
i prefer biden to trump
i have to look at the numbers when it
comes to gas prices inflation
etc
and when i look at the numbers i see
that those things are up all over the
world
and i see that
those are not phenomena
that depend on the american president to
any significant degree we've i'm not
gonna do
i respect you too much in the audience
to do my what can presidents do
about gas prices rant a second third
what must be probably the fifth time now
so i'm not going to do that but it is
exactly because i do look at the facts
that i come to the conclusions i come to
and christopher
or
keith i don't know
is welcome to call into my show anytime
and we can talk about it
next gill
wrote in
also about the trump rally over the
weekend
and said you seem to laugh at donald
trump i think you don't know very much
usa is a corporation
usa inc since yesterday usa
become a republic like if was before
and one more thing
donald know more than you
about political rules in michigan well
i couldn't possibly say it any better
myself and this is just such a wholesale
destruction
of my ideology and world view that i
won't even try to respond to gill
because it's just too much i just it's
just overwhelming okay
next email
is from darius darius says new
subscriber here
you killed air
with darlene
david i stumbled on your youtube videos
a couple of years ago and have been
evangelizing you to my friends and
finally decided it's time to pay
for solid journalism so i am now a
subscriber supporting the work you do i
love it just remember i do commentary
not journalism important distinction
darius goes on to say however
your interview with diana swafford it
was darlene swafar okay but it doesn't
matter i know who you mean
put you in the category
of why doesn't this guy have his own
msnbc or cnn show your interview
oh boy was absolutely brilliant you were
respectful even complementary your poker
face was amazing and critical to keep
her from walking off
you parsed the oil issue brilliantly
dude you need an agent to up your game
and get a broadcast cable show this
country needs people like you please try
to do more interviews like these well i
really appreciate that i have an agent
we are not trying to get me on msnbc or
cnn or fox or whatever i'm very happy
with what i'm doing i don't want to have
10 bosses at any of those places i don't
think they want me there either but i so
appreciate
the kind words
from darius about this
and we are trying to get more of those
interviews lined up with the 2020
candidates on the right and on the left
we're doing it all
we're doing it all
next let's go to an email from teresa
teresa said is there a way i can gift
more than one membership at a time
david said on air that there were over
600 hoping to become members i'd like to
offer several gifts anonymously thank
you yeah so teresa is asking a perfect
question
one of the biggest things people in the
audience wanted was they wanted to be
able to gift memberships on our website
they would write in they would say sir i
have a membership but i want to give
some memberships away can i do that and
up until two weeks ago the answer was no
but we listened we have a new plug-in on
our website joinedpakman.com which when
you go through the checkout now there's
a box and it says is this a gift and if
you check the box your membership will
be added to our queue which we can give
away we've given away about a hundred
memberships so far thanks to gifts but
we do have now it's not even 600 it's
now 670 people waiting for a membership
so we are going to try teresa to make
this a possibility where you can just do
10 at a time 20 at a time 30 you know
just dump memberships in we're going to
try
but in the meantime you can still gift
individual memberships one at a time
what a generous audience beautiful
spencer wrote in about my use of the
term bad faith
spencer says hey david i've been
watching your show for well over a year
now and have a request
that seems simple but it may take some
time to elaborate on the answer
could you give a definition or
explanation on the phrase bad faith in
terms of political questions and
comments i personally haven't had an
issue agreeing with you whenever you use
it but it may help others understand why
you use that phrase to dismiss certain
talking points and ideas from both the
right and left so here's the thing
there's two answers about what we mean
by bad faith
the first one is
you sort of know bad faith when you see
it and what i mean by that is you might
remember
when i appeared on the
jessie lee peterson show
and he asked me what is love
and i knew that it was a bad faith
question to try to wrap me up into some
kind of homophobic thing and so i didn't
even take it seriously i said you know
jesse you know love when you see it it's
sort of ethereal and i i don't know what
i said i just kind of laughed laughed it
off but what we mean by bad faith is
that there's an intent to deceive or
that you are not being genuine in your
intention so to give an example
when marsha blackburn asks
judge now just soon to be justice
katanji brown jackson
what is a woman
it's not that by definition asking what
a woman is is a bad faith question a
five-year-old would ask lots of
questions that are just they don't have
the information yet what is a woman okay
great or a three-year-old i don't know
when kids ask what's a woman what's a
man
but the point of the question
is deceptive it's not a mere curiosity
it's a bad faith in
attempt to get judge jackson to
pigeonhole herself with one definition
which will then be turned and used
against her for political reasons so
with bad faith
you have to understand context bad faith
is sort of like a dog whistle the idea
of a dog whistle is the same way that if
you blow a dog whistle the dogs hear it
but humans don't or at least it's not as
loud okay
um it's the same type of thing with dog
whistles where if i say if you didn't
understand listen imagine that you're
from
uh uh a society that has not had contact
with
the west call it okay
and i say to you
yeah you know
i'm trying to think of a good example if
i say to you yeah
there's we're going to look into
the people that control hollywood
like george soros
and steven spielberg right and i list a
bunch of jewish people
unless you know what to listen for
you don't realize that that's an
anti-semitic trope
and much like with a dog whistle you
have to be conditioned to hear it
you also have to understand context to
be able to identify bad faith questions
i hope that i'm being clear
i hope that i'm being clear in this but
uh an important question for sure
dave wrote in
and dave says
about my story on republican covid
deaths
david you should have mentioned their
base is substantially older than the
democrats i would bet out of the 73 000
florida deaths you mentioned you can add
another 20 000 because they are older
voters sixties to nineties i bet sixty
percent of republican at least great
show yeah we don't we just don't have
the numbers the question here is about
the uh partisan death gap in covid we
know it skews towards republicans we
just don't know by how much
and we don't know if by enough to make a
difference in any midterm elections but
i welcome any information we might have
about that
keith wrote in with an idea here's an
idea from keith david sir as your show
is an independent operation i know
maintaining a workable revenue stream is
an ongoing effort i have a one-word
solution for you
reruns reruns made the creators of shows
like friends and seinfeld billionaires
or very nearly so why not you
re-runs david reruns well i appreciate
the support keith but there is a
difference between the marble rye and
its replay value as a seinfeld episode
and what was in the news on august 10th
of uh 2012.
there's not that much replay value to
news shows so i love the idea in
practice i don't know if it works but
what does work is
we will sometimes weave together themed
episodes where we say let's take the
issue of climate and make an episode out
of our best interviews about climate
change we've done that and people
generally like it so that works just
reruns reruns i just don't know they're
good for a few months but i don't think
anyone's going to buy them but i
appreciate the thinking about how to
grow revenue last email today is from
doug who also
signs his email brian i i don't know why
people do this
anyway it doesn't matter
doug says david please refrain from
using the phrase guys or you guys
it's disrespecting the women in your
audience consider using folks or you
folks yet this is a regional thing
in in new england it's very con growing
up you just you just used guys
it was inclusive of everybody
and i'd never used folks i never used
use
i never used uh
y'all
um i i certainly don't intend to
disrespect any women
but if you agree with doug or brian
maybe you agree with brian and disagree
with doug i have no idea this is from
doug brian if you agree disagree let me
know your thoughts is it offensive when
i casually say guys i don't know if i
can take this republican bs anymore am i
being disrespectful to women when i say
that let me know we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com
to instantly access the bonus show also
remember that on tuesday
april 19
6 pm eastern we'll be doing the next
david pakman show viewer town hall it
will be live only on our second youtube
channel pacman live that's youtube.com
pacman live